autre élection présidentielle à celle de
2024 aux états unis pour laquelle donald
trump entretient le flou l'ex-président
américain est remonté sur scène la nuit
dernière en caroline du nord au
lendemain de l'annoncé par facebook de
le suspendre pour deux ans du réseau
social la correspondance à washington de
thomas bonnin 90 minutes d'un discours
qui avait tout l'air d'un meeting en vue
de la prochaine campagne présidentielle
pour sa première prise de parole
publique en dehors de floride depuis
qu'il a quitté la maison blanche au mois
de janvier
donald trump est apparu plus déterminé
que jamais car s'il a bel et bien
présenté le candidat républicain au
sénat en caroline du nord
le discours de l'ancien président était
surtout destiné à l'ensemble de ses
supporters en vue des deux prochaines
échéances qu'il a lui-même souligné les
élections de mi-mandat en 2022 et la
présidentielle donc 2024 pendant toute
la durée de sa prise de parole train pas
vanté son bilan tout en critiquant très
durement les premiers mois de joe biden
un bilan qu'il qualifie de désastreux
que ce soit sur l'aspect économique ou
encore sur la gestion de la frontière
sud des états unis
donald trump s'est montré très virulent
avec ce qu'il a régulièrement qualifié
de démocrates socialistes
autre thématique abordée la politique
internationale des états unis l'amérique
est humilié aux yeux du monde estime
trump qui est revenu sur la décision de
ba y donne de réintégrer la corde paris
sur le climat ou encore sur le dossier
du nord stream de ce gazoduc reliant la
russie à l'allemagne et auquel il
s'était fermement opposé mais le pays
qui a concentré le plus de critiques
c'est évidemment la chine pays que
l'ancien président tient pour
responsable de la pandémie
ils doivent payer at il lancé avant de
soutenir l'idée que les pays du monde
entier devaient annuler leurs decks
détenus par la chine afin d'obtenir
réparation sur la question de la
pandémie justement donald trump c'est là
encore vanté de son bilan notamment en
matière de production de vaccins et on a
aussi profité pour tourner en ridicule
le dr anthony fauci dont des milliers de
mails ont été publiés cette semaine et
que l'ancien président accuse d'avoir eu
tort sur tout enfin donald trump est
également revenu sur la dernière
élection présidentielle qu'il considère
encore comme je cite l'élection la plus
corrompu de l'histoire
évoquant les procédures lancées par son
camp dans différents états il a surtout
avancer ses idées pour faire évoluer la
législation en matière d'inscription sur
la liste électorale
on a donc vu trup tel qu'on l'avait
laissé ou presque
en début d'année un ancien président
loin d'avoir quitté le champ politique
d'autres meetings sont notamment prévues
en ce mois de juin et au match juillet
pour l'ancien locataire de la maison
blanche qui sont plus désireux que
jamais de la retrouver